what a woman I was about to talk about
you're never bleep crappy movie ahead
ready rolling and exit oh that was the
oldc I know it's gonna long day okay
think is that that way
yeah very good all right whatever you
ready okay I'm sorry
hitting myself in the head no it's not
been in there for a while will you get
out of here we are trying to do
something different and make better
that's the life sorry I can't
she's a frustrated princess who wants
more and she's going against her parents
wishes if we save this route we're going
to be a Disney film yeah you're a man
yes I'm World War one Steve pilot and
actually a surprise oh you'll love the
blue I have two different action step
little forward a little bit we didn't
like seriously I gotta go we did it I
gotta just not stairs as a corn general
send in the next subject is your views
because you were starting to laugh
alright urn damnit I saw you laughing
like yeah yeah alright give me a
second that's her name
great sanic said princess a fence key Oh
perfect
no no no you're not supposed to actually
talk with the people you saved you're
supposed to talk about nope you're
welcome
oh yeah lie about those guys I think I
like my life Oh should we keep going
thank you okay hey no Rebecca contractor
gets it all right it's so needlessly
long-winded and needlessly detail I
screwed it up we're gonna do it again
hey now we're back on track this guy
gets it so long-winded so legally detail
it's like a bedtime story from yeah this
is this is what I call a poor man's
close-up
all right you ready mine playing us out
then while I eat cake maybe cool you're
not eating had cake not eating hand cake
next to one of our playing electric know
you may be awesome well you're not
eating hand came in you may be awesome
but you're not eating hand cake next 200
women playing oh my god oh my god I
guess okay you may be awesome but you're
not eating hand cake you may be awesome
but you're not eating can I'm sorry
you may be awesome to the light go off
or something yeah nothing why is this
Irish I it should be a piece of cake
literally a few cake
[Laughter]
you